my wife is a saver and I'm a spender we
don't buy anything over $300 without
talking about it we don't give large
charitable gifts without us agreeing
that that's a good thing to give that to
a good person we'll go out to eat
somewhere and I'll go hey you know 40
years ago we owned that house right
there for about 2 days I flipped it and
she's like you're kidding no she goes a
friend of mine lived in that house I
bought houses the woman had never seen
you know that's weird if you think about
it but nowadays we would never do that
we get ready to buy a commercial
property or something we'll get in the
car and we'll go drive on Sunday
afternoon I'll go Winston and I are
looking at doing this deal over here and
here's the numbers on it she yeah okay
we're building our third house together
and that one will test you yeah sure cuz
you argue about stuff all the time I
mean we were picking out cabinet
hardware for God's sakes and I'm like I
don't like that she goes my kitchen I
went good point get it if you want it so
she gets the kitchen what do you get I'm
guessing the garage the basement I mean
there's all kinds of stuff I get believe
me I get plenty